be sure to check out Rob plays there you
can hang out with me while we play video
games and talk about life stuff
so what I want to do here is have a
discussion about Suicide Squad rebirth
and what I'm hoping is that at the end
of all this you'll have a better
understanding of the team and relation
to the new 52 and pre new 52
continuities
so while Suicide Squad rebirth number
one like all the rebirth special is
billed as being the perfect jumping off
point for readers wanting to follow the
team this version of The Suicide Squad
actually made its debut in Harley Quinn
and The Suicide Squad April Fool's
special number one which was published
in April of 2016 over a month prior to
the release of the DC Universe rebirth
special in this issue written by Robin
Williams and drawn by Jim Lee both of
whom along with artist Philip tan will
make up the creative team of the main
Suicide Squad series going forward
Harley Quinn is approached by Amanda
Waller to evaluate potential members of
a new Suicide Squad
to see if they make suitable additions
to the team as a result the version of
the team seen at the end of this comic
Polly Quinn Deadshot Captain Boomerang
katana and Killer Croc is nearly
identical to the line of this featured
in the Suicide Squad film demonstrating
a clear desire by DC to bring the
Suicide Squad title more in line with
their extended universe this principle
is also demonstrated by the fact that
Amanda Waller's appearance is
significantly different from her new 52
iteration where she was depicted as
young and extremely attractive and more
in line with her traditional look as
she's depicted as noticeably older and
heavier now with regards to the issue
the comic opens up with Amanda Waller
meeting with President Barack Obama at
the White House as he looks at a photo
of Harley Quinn white in the face of a
prison guard after a while the president
informs Amanda Waller that because the
Suicide Squad has been operating without
any governmental supervision as well as
a controversial nature of the tactics
they employ to recruit members and keep
them in line he's effectively shutting
the program down and an attempt to
change his mind while I suggest bringing
in colonel rick flagg jr. a decorated
war hero of high moral character to be
the public face of Suicide Squad also
known as Task Force X as a result the
president reluctantly agrees and allows
Task Force X to continuous operations
under Wohlers direction from here Waller
goes to visit Rick Flagg we find out
it's been detained in Guantanamo Bay for
disobeying an order that he felt would
endanger the lives of those under his
command which would lead to their deaths
now the appearance of Rick Flagg and his
issue is notable for
reasons first it symbolizes DC's
commitment to returning to the long
legacy of their comics and characters
that was one of the driving forces
behind the rebirth initiative rick flagg
was one of the central characters of
John Ostrom Drew's lengthy and renowned
run on the title in the late eighties in
the early 90s serving as a team's field
commander however when the DC Universe
was rebooted with a flashpoint event
Rick flag was mysteriously absent in the
new 52 universe that was created despite
the Suicide Squad existing two different
iterations during the new 52 era where
Waller informs rick flagg that The
Suicide Squad are villains that have had
bombs surgically implanted into their
brains that will detonate should they
step out of line she also offers flaca
position as the field commander now her
flag initially scoffs at her offer
Waller's persistent and makes an attempt
to convince him by appealing to Flags
deep sense of morality to convince him
to become the leader of the Suicide
Squad citing the fact that he would be
able to save lives and give the villains
that make up the team's roster a
much-needed moral compass from here we
cut the Harlequin Deadshot and Captain
Boomerang on a mission to Mongolia to
retrieve a scientist named Mark lung
bird who's been taken hostage by a group
of criminals calling themselves dog
O'War and forced to build a meta bomb
which would have the effect of turning
everyone within his blast radius into a
superhuman for 36 hours while
simultaneously stripping the powers of
any superhumans in the area for the same
length of time the scene at the Java war
have already given themselves
superpowers The Suicide Squad soon see
themselves outmatched after initially
finding the scientists and the bomb
however Lumbergh is soon captured and in
order to keep the meta bomb from falling
back into the hands of the criminals
Captain Boomerang severs the hands of
the scientists that are holding the case
with one of the razor-sharp boomerangs
realizing however that if the criminals
get lung burg back into their possession
that they'll be able to force him to
create another bomb Deadshot complies
with an order he receives to eliminate
the scientists before that can happen
now with the bomb secured and lung burg
dead the Suicide Squad detonate the bomb
in order to reverse his effects and
render the dog O'War powerless once
again and the team begins to make their
way out of Mongolia and so as the issue
comes to a close it's revealed that the
person in command of the team and the
one who gave Deadshot the order to kill
the scientist is actually Rick Flagg
who's accepted Wohlers offer and taken
the suicide squad under his command now
as far as the story goes this issue is
really nothing out of the ordinary we
are shown that the team will do what it
in order to complete their mission and
is willing to make the hard decisions
for the greater good as evidence by
killing an innocent scientist to keep
them from being captured by the enemy
and where his work could have
devastating consequences what really
stands out about this issue however is
the balance between the stated
objectives behind the rebirth initiative
what we see here is a modern take on the
team with a lineup of characters similar
to what we seen in the film which seeks
to accomplish the goal of capitalizing
on the bus surrounding the movie however
this does not come at the expense of the
legacy of the Suicide Squad and in fact
we see the legacy embrace in a way that
was absent in the new 52 if you see my
video on the new 52 you Amanda Waller
you'll notice that she was a longtime
director in charge of Task Force X and
has been returned to her pre new 52 look
and characterization and we also see the
return of a popular character that's
been missing from the DC Universe and
Rick Flagg since the idea behind rebirth
was to highlight the legacy of DC
characters while still presenting a
fresh take on them I'd say that this
issue is pretty successful in capturing
the spirit of DC rebirth as a whole but
with that being said we're going to go
ahead and bring this video to an end let
me know what you guys think about DC
rebirth and Suicide Squad rebirth I'm
kind of curious and I will catch you
guys on it peace